la médecine française française pardon
at elle inventé la sage-femme
électronique cette formule choc
schématise un peu la réalité j'en
conviens mais tout de même il reste
l'invention d'un ingénieur invention
d'une machine électronique qui branché
sur la patiente permet de déceler le
meilleur moment pour entreprendre un
accouchement difficile accouchement qui
jusqu'à présent étaient provoqués par
des perfusions d'hormones relativement
douloureuse l'emplette de claude crespo
ceux qui sont bleus c'est en fait un
appareil capable de déclencher
artificiellement les accouchements
cette technique est déjà utilisée
couramment soit pour des raisons
médicales précises ce pour une
convenance personnelle
il suffit de perfuser de l'ocytocine une
hormone qui a le pouvoir de provoquer
les contractions
ce système de régulation hormonale est
déjà pratiqué pour un cinquième des sept
familles accouchements réalisés en
france chaque année la nouveauté avec
cette pompe c'est qu'on peut effectuer
une perfusion automatique adaptées à
chaque cas ce point de type est relié à
un monitoring cet appareil placé sous la
pompe qui surveille en permanence le
travail de la mère et du foetus la pompe
calcul à tout instant la dose de sitôt
si nécessaire pour que l'accouchement se
fasse avec une bonne progression et
selon un optimum là sont aussitôt sin
est pourvu d'un dispositif qui étudie en
même temps le rythme cardiaque de
foetale et s'il ya des anomalies du
rythme cardiaque du foetus il ya des
anomalies des contractions de leur
amplitude de leur surface de leur
quantité
mais à cette pompe diminue son débit où
s'arrête nous pouvons beaucoup plus
aisément déclenché le travail quand les
conditions ctk le permettent
et ceci avec une beaucoup plus grande
sécurité qu'en faisant manuellement et
vous savez que pratiquement tous les cas
des accouchements se passe la nuit
est-ce qu'on peut déclencher un travail
pour que les accouchements les
accouchements se passe de jour
oui c'est une tendance actuelle qui est
fait dans la plupart des services de
gynécologie obstétrique en fonction de
la demande c'est ce que nous apportons
ce ce que nous appelons le déclenchement
de convenance pour le couple et pour
l'équipe que ce fric al ça permet
d'avoir une équipe très renforcée dans
la journée et donc d'améliorer les
conditions de sécurité
mais en même temps c'est la fin de
l'accouchement naturel absolument pas
car il ya beaucoup d'accouchements qui
se passe montaner mans avant la date
qu'elle vous prouve elle est trop gras
mais est ce là on les respecte d'autres
pas si les personnes veulent accoucher
sans aucune déclenchement c'est elle qui
décide c'est pas nous
cet appareil ne remplacera pas le
travail de la sage femme mais il
deviendra une aide précieuse aux
diagnostics pour prendre en main le
déroulement du travail
cette pompe sera commercialisé d'ici la
fin de l'année